oh my oh my goodness
they really went there i mean i can
abide a lot but this might be a step
too far i mean bok choy in beefa
really i just cannot believe they went
there i guess
possibly if it was vegan or something
weird like that
but come on hey guys pete here this will
be my for all mankind
season 2 episode 8 breakdown it's
starting to feel like we're getting into
the end game here a lot of stuff
happening
real quick i'll give you a spoiler
warning if you haven't watched this
episode yet this video will definitely
spoil it so hit the subscribe button
go watch it get caught up and then come
back and with that out of the way let's
get started yes
things are happening and things are
moving president reagan is
congratulating ellen for a job well done
over the 1980s version of skype they
discuss apollo soyuz
ellen gives a strong argument that they
still have the moral high ground in the
situation and they decide to continue
with that
then the president tells ellen that he
wants to nominate her to be the director
of nasa
everyone in attendance thinks this is a
great idea
and realistically as far as the space
programs concerned
it probably would be bradford and margot
make the point that
the president will listen to her because
she's an astronaut
and more than that she's the girl who
caught the tank
something that people watched on tv
across the united states
it was a big deal but of course ellen is
the only one who
is hesitant and we can gather that this
is because of her relationship with pam
in the last episode we saw she was being
pulled in two different directions
and this idea of being nominated will
definitely get her to where she's gonna
have to make a decision
we also find out through bradford that
the soviets have delayed
the buron launch at least from what we
see it looks like she got away with
tipping off sergey
he even mentions that see i told you
they have smart people over there they
probably figured it out themselves and
after bradford leaves she tells her
assistant
they need to get sergey back so that
they can finish
planning the mission in their
conversation we find out that gordo's
flight is on deck
and he's getting ready to go back to the
moon we see him getting ready he looks
nervous
but then ed comes in to visit him and
they have a moment together
a little back and forth some mutual
encouragement some patting each other on
the back
and it really works to get you pumped up
for gordo and we see his shuttle take
off
he looks ecstatic we hear him say i'm
back baby i'm back
and yeah good to see gordo back in the
saddle
a little later in the episode we see his
triumphant return
he touches down he gets a needle drop
with
back in black playing and a nice welcome
when he enters the base
and he definitely looks anxious but
seems to be managing it
beyond being a little bit short with the
guy who's showing him around
he seems mostly concerned about tracy
and he finds out that she's out with the
marines which is a surprise
eventually they cross paths and we see
that he's contemplating making his move
we see him looking at a picture of them
when they were first married
it all comes together when he finds her
smoking a cigarette and she asked him
she says he looks good and she wants to
know what's going on
he breaks down and tells her the truth
about everything that happened the last
time he was there
and tells her straight up that he's
there to get her back and lets her know
that he went to sam's house and told him
to his face
what's interesting is that she doesn't
really object
she doesn't necessarily encourage him
either but she sort of ends things just
saying
catch me if you can seeing him overcome
his fear
seeing him getting everything together
makes you feel a little bit uneasy about
a situation
over the last two episodes a lot of
people have been theorizing that there's
going to be tragedy at the end of his
story
something with him or with tracy or
perhaps something with him because of
tracy
trying to save her or something like
that and there probably is something to
that if you really take a look back at
how his stories develop this season back
on earth we do see molly go visit an eye
doctor about the problems she's having
and she learns that she has normal
tension glaucoma
this is a condition where her optic
nerve is damaged
and we all know that this is because of
the radiation
she more or less tells the doctor what
happened
in a way that she knows like hey don't
tell anybody about this
but the bad news is that she's gonna go
blind no matter what she's in for a
progressive loss of vision
and that will end with permanent
blindness
and of course that means she's never
gonna be able to fly again
this is not what she's wanting to hear
she sort of leaves in a hurry
with the doctor calling after or saying
that hey the nasa flight surgeons are
good they're gonna catch it there's no
way you can trick them with this more or
less
and we see her get in a jet and go
flying and it almost felt like she might
kill herself here like that's how bad
this is for her
she takes the plane up until it stalls
out and it's fitting because
her future is up in the air at this
point i really have no idea how she's
going to move on from that
at home molly is watching tv we hear in
the background that there was a truck
bomb that blew up in panama
and wayne tries to talk to her tries to
give her a beer
and she doesn't see him standing there
and he figures out that there's
something wrong with her eyes so they
have a fight
and that leads to her telling him what
really happened on the moon
at jsc we find out that yes it was in
fact
a very bad idea for margot to tell elena
the story about bill peeing his pants
and the nickname peanut
they get into it and she mentions maybe
he should have worn a diaper during
gemini
and she drops a peanut later elena finds
out that bill
quit and margot tells her that she needs
to make it right
and after a blow up we see margot throw
it back at her and says this is what you
do
this is how you always get yourself
fired you can't get along basically
she storms out and margot doesn't back
down bill's important to the program
and she feels that elena needs to be
able to
do these kinds of things needs to make
something like this right
if she's going gonna continue working at
nasa she does come around she goes to
bill's house
and this was one of the strongest scenes
in the episode i thought
they really nailed this i mean let's be
honest bill
is a pain in the ass and you could
understand why elena was pushing back
against that
but he lays out the truth of what
happened and the shame that he had with
that
and it makes you feel for the guy and
you see that what happened to him
this embarrassing moment was all related
to his passion for the space
program for doing his job and you can
see that elena has that same
passion they have that in common and
it's rough because he says you know here
i was celebrating
i had never been a part of anything like
this before
and then everything crashed down around
him so she makes the decision to tell
him about the time that she spent on the
street
after we saw margot turn her away at the
end of last season
she had to resort to eating out of
dumpsters and she got
shot by one of the restaurant owners and
she was too afraid to stay at the
hospital
because she was illegal to actually get
the care that she needed
so her bringing up her own shame telling
him about it and that she was genuinely
sorry she threw his in his face
plus the realization that they have the
passion for space in common
i thought it all really worked well and
i loved the way they wrote the ending
with him kind of instinctively throwing
out an
answer to jeopardy playing on the tv and
then her
instinctively mentioning that he didn't
phrase it as a question
and yeah he gives her a beer and they
bury the hatchet
i especially like the latest face as
she's looking at all this crazy space
stuff he has in his apartment
and him just wanting to get rid of her
and as viewers we can't help but notice
how nerdy they are about space
and how this will probably play out with
them becoming
friendly if not allies just quickly to
go back to ellen she does eventually
tell pam about the job offer but says
that she's not gonna take it
obviously before thomas payne died this
was her plan
in her mind and her heart she had
decided she wanted to be with pam more
than she wanted to be at nasa
after he died it doesn't seem as solid
though
and we see that pam doesn't know what to
think she's the one who's in a tough
spot now because she knows that ellen
has made the commitment
and you have to imagine that she thinks
that ellen might
regret it if she leaves at this point in
time
there's really no good choices for pam
so it'll be interesting to see how this
plays out
kelly does go through with the idea of
going to look for her biological father
and before she gets her grounding she
meets her half-sister
and catches a glimpse of her father
working in the kitchen
if you watch the extra in the apple app
she makes a video
call to danny and tells him that she's
going to meet her father and kind of
works through her feelings
and we can see as she's asking her
half-sister who she doesn't know
all these different questions just how
overwhelming the idea of actually
talking to her father gets
i made the joke in the beginning about
the beefa and the fact that she's not
familiar with vietnamese food
really adds to the tension and
underlines how separated from her
culture
she is the culture of her family in the
end she decides not to talk to him
a difficult decision but i guess at
least she knows where he's at
and maybe down the road she'll find
herself in a place where she can
actually talk to him
at the very least i do think that she
should take her half-sister's
advice and come back and try the broken
rice and pork because that
is an awesome dish one last side story
before we get to the main event
and that is margo she's in her office
getting dressed and her assistant
suggests that she wears red because
sergey likes red
and margot tries to play it off like why
would she care about that
a few minutes later she arrives at their
meeting wearing red
and he does compliment her on the color
they discuss the handshake and they have
to get in the prop to try things out
and while things get a little frisky
they get a little bit
intimate inside there and things seem to
be progressing they seem to be going to
the next
level of course they get interrupted
before anything can actually happen
but at least at this point it seems like
there's real chemistry
and there's interest on both sides so
back
on the moon we see tracy and gordo in
the lsam together
she gives him the controls he flies it
and when they arrive at the mining site
the marines see movement above the
crater and they have to go investigate
they find two cosmonauts that look like
they're doing something scientific as
far as i can tell
they're just doing cosmonauts stuff they
aren't doing anything that would be
threatening but this is the situation
they're on the moon
with everything else going on tensions
are high and because they have this
case that looks somewhat suspicious it
makes sense that the marines would be on
high alert
we see bradford back on earth telling
them to make contact over the radio
on their frequency the marines don't
have anybody that can understand russian
i guess
they do have an armband with commands
but it's pretty clear that they can't
understand what they're saying which is
probably just
hey wait a minute give us a second so
that we can respond to you in english
they make a move for the case and things
pop off
the female marine that was piscotty's
friend ends up taking a shot
and the cold war turns hot at least
right there at that moment both
cosmonauts end up shot
the poor first guy catches on fire there
must have been a spark when the bullet
entered his suit
and the oxygen inside caught fire so
this guy was burning alive
inside his suit the other guy's losing
air
but they're able to use duct tape to
temporarily fix his suit
although he still has a bullet wound
underneath there and it turns out that
they were going to the case so that they
could get their translation
card and reply to the marines so it's a
big mess
they report what happens to bradford
they call tracy for medevac
and it's hard to say how this is gonna
play out
obviously they're gonna be taking this
injured soviet back to
jamestown and that in itself is pretty
weird when you think about it
and the americans killed an unarmed
cosmonaut there's really no getting
around that
we did see earlier that there was an
incident in panama
but at the same time sergey came back so
they're still planning apollo soyuz
and regardless of how the actual
governments respond
you have to wonder about how the other
cosmonauts are gonna take this
it's definitely gonna lead somewhere and
we're gonna have to wait and see
and i guess that's about it right that's
pretty much
everything that happened except oh yeah
how could i forget
karen and danny had sex and you know
what can you really say about this
the one thing that i can say is kind of
funny is the way that it played out
the seeds had been planted so people
were definitely worried that in the last
episode this was gonna happen
and there was a collective sigh of
relief after she
left after the kiss happened and then
boom here it is they actually
did it and from my perspective it kind
of sucks i'm not a fan of it
i can't really figure out where they're
going i just hope they're going
somewhere
and of course he falls in love and she
has to send him away
and i have to think that this is
something that will come back
later i mean there may be immediate
consequences in karen's story
but if you think about future seasons
obviously they're setting up kelly and
danny to be
important 10 years down the road so in
kelly's case she had this
almost reunion with her birth father and
while that doesn't do much for the story
right now
neither did the stuff we saw with elena
last season
it was interesting it wasn't bad in and
of itself
it just didn't really fit with what was
going on with the rest of the story
and i think there's a pretty good
parallel between elena season one
and kelly in season two the danny stuff
it's a little bit harder to figure out
but
i'm tending to think that it's going to
be more about him as a character than it
is about her
and that's really the best way that i
can think to spin it because it's just
not really
something that makes sense or is popular
or seems to make her story any better
and yeah it happened so there's that
other than that
i think it was a pretty awesome episode
and i was surprised at how
exciting it was to see gordo go back to
space
that does like i said earlier make me
worry a little bit about his trajectory
but it's not impossible that he'll get a
happy ending this season
i guess what stands out about this
episode compared to the previous
few is it just hit the ground running it
was just one thing after the other
and it gave it real momentum towards the
end
molly going blind is an interesting
twist for that character
i expected that she would get cancer and
that she would eventually die
but this is a little bit different she
may end up living but she has to give up
this one thing that
she really cares about which is flying
her story at this point feels just a
little bit added on
it doesn't seem as central to things but
she's still a great character that i
hope we see more of
it actually slipped my mind that gordo
never told tracy the truth about what
happened with danny on his last mission
to the moon he just went to the
therapist
and never let her know about how messed
up he was it makes their separation and
everything that's happened
since hit a little differently when you
think about it
marco getting a little close with sergey
is fun to watch
but it's a little hard to see how that
could end well at best
one of them would have to end up
defecting and they both seem completely
dedicated to their respective
jobs let me know in the comments what
you think about the chances of apollo
soyuz happening
plus whatever else you've got on your
mind because there's a lot to talk about
here
and this video's length is getting away
from me so i think this is the right
place to stop it
and we can pick it back up down below
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon
you